[Music]
if you are one of those men and women
who dream of working as princes and
princesses at Disney World don't think
that it is only about smiling and being
beautiful only a few of us will have the
chance to get the parts and they will
quickly realize that it is harder than
it looks
just wait until you see how this job can
become dangerous if this is your first
time visiting our channel don't forget
to subscribe and please give this video
a big thumbs up today we are showing you
ten strange requirements to work as a
Disney princess the look to make
children believe that you are a Disney
Princess you have to look like one this
is not surprising but this is something
that will shatter the dreams of most
aspiring princesses first most girls
should be between 18 and 23 years old
this makes sense as they are playing the
roles of teenagers but you can still
work as a princess until you're 30 and
then you might want to switch for the
mascot costume instead for the height
most princesses are between 5 foot 4
inches and 5 foot 7 inches tall but you
will also find some characters who are
shorter like fairies Alice or Wendy when
it comes to weight the largest size for
a dress is a 10 when you think that the
average size for an American woman is 16
it seems unfortunate to show only one
body type to little girls who will
believe that you have to be thin to be
beautiful but most importantly you have
to look like the character and the other
girls portraying her one woman was fired
because her mouth was very different
than all the other girls and don't think
that you will get to choose your
favorite princess if the casting
directors think that you look like valve
you will work as well and you should
consider yourself lucky because most
girls won't get the chance to be any
princess the audition this is the first
thing you should do if you want to
become a Disney Princess look for the
dates online and find the nearest
audition this is when you will realize
that the 700 other girls in the room
have the same dream too and that you
will have to compete against them the
audition is really long and can even
take two days the first thing the
casting directors will do is see if you
look like any Disney Princess this means
that you might not get a chance no
matter how good you are then you will
have to learn a dance routine and
perform it the most important thing is
not being the best dancer but being the
most entertaining just keep smiling and
try to do something that will make the
children laugh a girl failed the dance
routine and ended up being chosen anyway
because she had a positive attitude so
you don't have to worry too much if the
casting directors like you you will then
get a chance
read a script to show off your acting
skills do some improv and then do the
interview some girls will even get the
chance to try on the costume and this is
usually the last step to becoming a
Disney Princess unfortunately if it
doesn't suit you you might have done all
this for nothing
no matter what just keep smiling and if
you don't get the part just try again
next year
the training don't think that it's easy
to become a Disney Princess it is much
more than just smiling and looking
beautiful the training usually takes
five days and you have to study the film
intensively with a trainer
it might sound fun but you will actually
have to remember a lot of lines from the
movies and learn everything there is to
know about your character
there are worksheets that you have to
complete so you'd better know how to
answer questions like who is her
favorite person or what does she do in
her spare time you will also learn how
to move like the princess that you're
portraying and imitate her voice another
important thing to do is to learn to
write like the Disney princess they all
have their own signature and you want to
be able to do it perfectly you will also
have to watch other princesses like you
greeting guests this is how you will
learn to imitate not only the princess
but also the other girls portraying her
it might sound like you have a lot of
stuff to learn
but imagine doing that for many
princesses some girls play different
characters so they have to do this
several times to make sure that they are
perfect for every role who said that
being a Disney princess was easy
the preparation you have heard it before
you have to suffer to be beautiful but
don't worry becoming a Disney princess
won't be too painful unless you are very
impatient it takes about an hour to do
the makeup and dressing up the first
thing you have to do is your makeup and
don't think that there is going to be
any professional makeup artist to help
you every princess has to learn how to
do her own makeup perfectly they give
you everything you need and also teach
you how to do it properly during
training then you have to put on the wig
and make sure it stays on your head all
day you can even have contacts to change
your eye color to make sure that you
look just like the character the final
step is putting on your dress which can
take five to ten minutes you will also
have to do a lot of adjustments and
touch-ups during the day the cosmetic
team checks your makeup before you go on
sets to make sure that everyone looks
perfect it's really awkward when someone
is disapproved because their arms got
too chubby or they had an acne breakout
all the Cinderella's have to look the
same and this is why it is important to
take it seriously so even if you see in
the movies that Disney Princesses just
woke up like this
this is really an unrealistic Beauty
standard
character when you work as a Disney
princess you don't act like the
character you are the character that
means that no matter what happens you
have to stay the perfect princess that
you are paid to be there are so many
rules that they are always afraid of
being in trouble they cannot sit they
cannot cross their arms and they should
always do the voice Snow White is one of
the hardest characters to do because of
her high-pitched voice the girl playing
her role said that she developed
inoperable nodes over time so it will
forever be difficult for her to speak or
sing the princesses also cannot talk
about anything outside Disney for
example Aurora can't say who was her
favorite superhero because this is not
part of her universe another thing that
you might have noticed is that all the
people working there have to do the
Disney point which means pointing with
two fingers they believe that it is less
true than pointing with one finger one
Disney princess even claims she was
fired because of that mistake but what
must be really difficult is staying in
character even when really bad things
happen a princess said that a kid
accidentally peed on her dress and she
had to wear it all day while trying to
ignore the smell when we know all this
we think that it's better to be
imperfect normal people The Improv to
stay in character you are also required
to be the best in improv kids are going
to ask you a lot of questions and you
always need to have a good answer the
princesses are not allowed to say no so
no matter what happens they will have to
find a solution to guest problems
Pocahontas is one of the most difficult
characters to play because she really
existed and children know about her
story one time a little boy came to her
and said that his class visited her
grave last year we don't know how
Pocahontas answered but it was probably
a tough one smart kids are a lot of
trouble it is also hard to play a
character who speaks another language
because you have to find a reason why
you can't speak Chinese when you are
Mulan or French when your bell some
people just ask really random questions
like how many poison apple Snow White
can fit in her mouth and still be able
to talk the answer is - a girl also saw
Prince Adam as a beast and asked what
did he do that was so bad to be turned
into a beast again we don't know how we
would answer this one but this little
girl is a smart one the strength working
as a Disney princess can be really
difficult it is not only about being
beautiful greeting guests and taking
pictures most of them have to work eight
and a half hours a day sometimes for
five to seven days a week they work 45
minutes and then have a 15-minute break
but sometimes it is so hot
outside that it becomes unhealthy to
work for so long when the weather
reaches 90 to 100 degrees they will have
more time to take a break and the magic
never stops so many princesses are still
working on holidays like Christmas but
the pay isn't that good for that kind of
job one girl said that she started at
thirteen fifty an hour and the most she
could make was sixteen dollars an hour
that's not a lot of money for all the
requirements that they have
moreover hanging out with Disney
Princesses is not always fun it's like
being in a high school where they are
considered to be the Mean Girls
they say that being a princess is like
being in a sorority so they might be
friends but a lot of people are jealous
of them it seems like there is a lot of
drama as many guests saw Cinderella
taking illegal substances her job must
be really hard if she has to do this to
get through her day the secret if you
ever work as a Disney Princess you will
probably be really proud of it you will
post many pictures of your look on
social media and tell all your friends
about your new job so you might be a
little disappointed to learn that you
actually cannot say anything about your
job as a princess what happens in Disney
stays in Disney social media is a big
problem they are not allowed to post
pictures or talk about things that they
did as characters these girls can't even
tell their family and friends which
character they are and even when someone
they know comes to Disney to visit them
they have to pretend that they are just
like any other guest when they are
Disney Princesses they are not
themselves anymore this is why a lot of
members of the Disney cats become best
friends because they are the only ones
they can talk to we even heard about
many princes and princesses dating each
other and making out in secret somewhere
in Disney World but make sure their boss
never hears about this the only reason
why we know about all this is that
former Disney Princesses revealed their
secrets after quitting their jobs but
those who work at Disney right now would
get in trouble for saying all this the
danger you might think that nothing bad
can happen when you're working with kids
and most of the time they are not the
problem but the grown-ups are
irresponsible a lot of parents encourage
their kids to hit mascots and Disney
Princesses
even though they did nothing wrong they
just seemed to think it is fun to annoy
them and see how they will react there
are also a lot of creepy men trying to
flirt with them Disney Princesses are
used to getting phone numbers and even
see people asking them to marry them but
some men can do things that are really
inappropriate for example Snow White
said that an old man would visit her
every Saturday and tried to kiss her
then one day
he realized that she was the only snow
white with brown eyes
he threatened to get rid of all the
other princesses with blue eyes so he
could be with her this girl had to
report him to security and his annual
pass was revoked but the most popular
princess was actually Pocahontas she
said that a lot of dads hit on her would
take pictures alone with her and
wouldn't be shy to say inappropriate
things no matter what happens they have
to deal with the situation make sure
that all the other guests are happy and
never stop smiling the smile the most
beautiful makeup any girl can wear is a
smile and it is true for Disney
Princesses - no matter what we said
previously Disney princesses have to
keep a smile on their face as soon as
guests can see you you have to be
smiling for at least an hour straight
and if you ever stop people will quickly
think that you're rude and you will get
in trouble your boss doesn't want to see
any picture without you smiling a cast
member revealed that her face literally
hurt the first few weeks but she had to
keep smiling to be the perfect woman
that they expected her to be fortunately
there are also a lot of reasons to smile
Disney Princesses can sometimes prank
each other in the break room Snow White
and Cinderella were hiding under Tiana's
dress then when Belle entered the room
they popped out and scared her there are
also so many cute kids that will make
your heart melt because they are so
happy to see you these are all good
reasons to smile every day so now that
you know all this do you think that you
would be able to be a Disney Princess
don't be shy to tell us what you think
in the comments section below and that's
it for ten strange requirements to work
as a Disney princess if you can't get
enough of Disney don't forget to watch
15 Disney princes reimagined as real
people thanks for watching
[Music]